صمتا صمتا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انها حرب عالميه عندما يتبادل الامريكيون
والروسي اطلاق النار سنكون في عالم مختلف
فنحن نتعامل مع احد اكبر الجيوش في العالم
[موسيقى]
حرب عالميه ثالثه جمله خفيفه على اللسان
ثقيله جدا على الارض والميزان هذه الحرب
تعني نهايه الحضاره وبدء عصر الاندفاع قد
يكون البشر فيها في خبر كان نعم كان هناك
بشر وشجر وحجر هكذا سيحكي من بقي من
المخلوقات لكن مهلا مهلا هل نحن في الطريق
الى هذه الحرب الخبيثه هل هناك علامات او
مؤشرات تنذر باقترابها وما شان العرب بحرب
قد تندلع في الغرب الامر يزداد حيره يا
ساده دول قليله اختلفت فيما بينها فقررت
اباده العالم ستهدم المعبد عليها وعلى
اعدائها وعلى من ليس له شان بها يا الهي
الامور تحدث حقا والعوده للوراء اصبحت
صعبه جدا ان لم تكن مستحيلا فما هي
العلامات التي تدل على اق الحرب العالميه
الثالثه للاجابه عن كل هذه الاسئله واكثر
دعونا نغوص في اعماق هذا الفيديو
اوكرانيا بدايه النهايه نعم العالم متخوف
من قيام حرب العالميه ثانيه الحرب التي
اذا اندلعت الان فانها ستكون اشد ضراوه من
سابقتها وهي الحرب الاعلف في التاريخ كله
لان القوه التدميريه للجيوش الان اضعاف ما
كانت عليه في الماضي ومنذ بدايه الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا والكل يترقب اندلاعا
حرب العالميه الثالثه التي تواجه فيها
روسيا حلف شمال الاطلسي زاد من اشتعال
التوقعات باندلاع هذه الحرب العالميه
التحرش العسكري الصيني بتايوان والمخاوف
من حدوث غزو لها على طريقه الروس في
اوكرانيا ما يضطر الولايات المتحده للرد
عسكريا على بكين
يقول المثل اذا تعاركت القرود افسدت
المحصول والقرود هنا هي الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها من جهه وروسيا والصين وحلفاؤهما
من جهه اخرى اما المحصول فهي بقيه دول
العالم سواء من تدخلت في الحرب ام من ليس
لها حول ولا قوه هي حرب لا احد يقوى على
تحمل نتائجها ولكن هي اخر الحلول للدول
العظمى المتحاربه وكل الطرق الحاليه لا
تقود الا الى الحرب فعلى الجانب الروسي
ومع بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا على ان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حاله التاهب
النووي ليصبح اكثر من سته الاف راس نوويه
جاهزه للانطلاق بانتظار ضغطه زر من الزعيم
الروسي في الطرف الاخر حلف النيتو يعد
العده للحرب واعضاء الحلفيه تعهدون بانفاق
ما لا يقل عن اثنين بالمئه من ناتجهم
المحلي الاجمالي على
العسكريه الوطنيه وعشرين بالمائه على
الاقل من هذا المبلغ على المعدات العسكريه
الجديده والبحث والتطوير والحرب تقترب
اكثر من قبل لكن يبدو ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا ترى ذلك فهي تنشر ما بين 100
الى 200 قنبله نوويه في اوروبا على اقل
تقدير هذه القنابل يمكن لنسخه منها ان
تحدث احد عشر ضعف تاثير القنبله النوويه
التي القيت على هيروشيما اليابانيه في
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه فعن اي قوه
تدميريه نتحدث وتنشر واشنطن هذا العدد من
القنابل النوويه في خمس دول اعضاء في حلف
شمال الاطلسي النيتو هي المانيا وبلجيكا
وايطاليا وهولندا وتركيا روسيا لم تقف
ساكنه ايضا وايه تنشر بعضا من اسلحتها
النبويه في بيلاروسيا لتقف راضعا امام
الدول الاوروبيه
ننسى ان في احشاء المخازن الروسيه تسكن
قنبله القيصر التي تعادل
3300 ضعف من القوه التدميريه لقنبله
هيروشيما اذا فبعد نشر الذخائر النوويه
لكلا الطرفين لنقل هابل فم المليان نعم هي
هذه العلامه الكبرى التي ستقودنا الى طرح
نظريه اقتراب الحرب العالميه الثالثه ليس
ذلك فحسب فان كان النيتو تحالفا عسكريا في
الطرف المقابل هناك حلف يكبر اكثر فاكثر
مع مرور الوقت انهم التحالف بريكس الحلف
الاقتصادي الذي سيتحول لتحالف عسكري
والهدف هو الدفاع عن المصالح للدول
الاعضاء في هذا الحلف والمؤشرات تدل على
ذلك مع كل انضمام لاعضاء جدد في البريكس
من العرب الى افريقيا
المناوشات والمماحات لم تعد مح
[موسيقى]
ان تستخدمها لاغراض عسكريه وها هو الطين
يزداد بالله بعد ان اصبحت مملكه مثل حليفا
شبه رسمي لروسيا والصين وبعد ان اشرفت
بكين على اعاده علاقات السعوديه مع ايران
وكان هذا الخلف يتحضر فعلا للحرب العالميه
وذلك باستماله اقوى حلفاء العرب من
السعوديه ومصر والجزائر وكذلك الامارات
التي حطها رئيسها مؤخرا لزياره بوتين في
روسيا وبوتين لا يلعب ما يبدو انه يتحضر
جيدا للحرب القادمه مع الحلفاء كالصين
وكوريا الشماليه وايران والسعوديه
والجزائر وبقيه العرب خصوصا مع تخلي العرب
عن امريكا التي خذلتهم عديد المرات
واستغلتهم لمصالحها واما في افريقيا فلا
يختلف الحال عن شبه جزيره العرب الافارقه
يخرجون من الجلباب الامريكي والغربي يدخل
في حضن الدب الرو والهدف والتحصل بحليف
قوي قبل الحرب العالميه القادمه التي باتت
بوادرها تلوح في الافق فبدا السودان ولحقت
بين نيجر والجابون والقائمه مفتوحه
للزياده في اي لحظه نعم افريقيا لديها
واحده من اسرع المناطق نموا في العالم
واكبر مناطق التجاره الحره واكثر النظم
البيئيه تنوعا وهي واحده من اكبر مجموعات
التصويت الاقليمي في الامم المتحده ولا
غربتين كانت افريقيا بثرواتها وعلى راسها
اليورانيوم سببا في الحرب العالميه
فالاختلاف جائكم بين الغرب وروسيا والصين
على من سيسيطر على القاره السمراء لتصبح
افريقيا واحده من علامات نشوب الحرب
العالميه الثالثه
معارك الرقائق الطاحنه حرب طاحنه ومعارك
شعواء تقودها امريكا لمواجهه الصين
الامريكان
ثغره امن قومي انها معركه الرقائق
الالكترونيه او ما يسمى باشباه الموصلات
واشنطن التي منع الدول العالم من تصدير
هذه الرقائق الى الصين بينما تعيش
الولايات المتحده اسوا عهودها مع تلك
الرقائق وبعد ان كانت واشنطن تسيطر على
30% من الانتاج العالمي لاشباه الموصلات
صارت حاليا تسيطر على نحو 10% فقط لذا
ذهبت لاحتضان تايوان مملكه الرقائق توصف
الرقائق الالكترونيه بكونها عصب المستقبل
لقطاع التكنولوجيا عاده ما يطلق عليها نفط
المستقبل لدخولها في جميع التقنيات
المتقدمه وعلى راسها توجيه الصواريخ
النوويه والفرد صوتيه لتصيب اهدافها بدقه
وسيطره الصين عليها قد تعني اندلاع الحرب
وحرمان الصين من الرقاق قد يعني اشعال
فتيل الحرب ايضا لكن هذه المره من الجانب
الصيني وفي كل الاحوال فالرقائق هذه هي
احدى العلامات التي تدل على اقتراب اندلاع
الحرب العالميه الثالثه ما بين امريكا من
جهه والصين وروسيا من جهه اخرى تكثر
علامات اقتراب الحرب العالميه وهنا يظهر
السؤال مع ظهور كل تلك العلامات هل ترى ان
موعد الحرب العالميه الثالثه قد اقترب ام
لا
[موسيقى]